but a new article in the new york times
smarter living Section argues
perfectionism can actually harm
productivity it's called it's never
going to be perfect so just get it done
the article says putting too much
research and time into a project where
the writing in an email or making a
presentation can damage the end result
the author of that article and editor of
smart living is Tim Herrera he joins us
at the table good morning good morning
clearly you're thinking you're not
perfect so why should the rest of us V
what's your argument against
perfectionism so the idea that we should
be obsessed with achieving a perfect
result for everything that we do is kind
of a mirage and it's something that
we're never going to achieve and
realistic you say it's unrealistic and
even if we got there what looks perfect
to us may not look perfect to somebody
else yes striving for it so rather than
putting so much effort in going over
such minor details that our incremental
improvements that even rather focus more
on just completing it being satisfied
with what you've done and doing the good
work behind you quote Voltaire who is
attributed with saying perfect is the
enemy of good yeah so it's just a great
kind of mindset to go into this you know
we're sort of just so obsessed with
perfection and achievement and you know
really we're kind of setting ourselves
up for failure because we're never gonna
reach these weird lofty goals that we've
just set ourselves up for so rather we
should just kind of think about the
journey the road is the goal right so
how do you know when good is good enough
when did you planned it to be perfect
yes and so it's just one of those things
where you have to have a little bit of
introspection a little bit of
self-awareness and realize when you
reach that point of kind of diminishing
returns where you're making changes that
you think are improvements but really
maybe you're just kind of making it
different rather than taking it better
this advice doesn't really apply to all
lines of work right if you're in a
nuclear lab story familiar you should
have got the label with those
allegations you know I mean would you
say this applies to everybody it's
generally applicable you can kind of
apply it to different scenarios and you
know kind of built into this article are
ways to kind of get around this idea of
striving for it and rather just
completing it so one of the things that
I write it on the article is focusing on
micro goals and so what I mean by that
is
slicing up a given project or a given
task into the tiniest units of progress
so that along the way it's your
achievement you're racking up a lot of
little wins you're making sure that
you're keeping yourself accountable
you're making progress and you're not so
focused on the end goal but rather just
the process that's gonna get you there
you say there are two types of people
maximizers and satisfiers
yes Maximizer satisficers is that a word
you made up I did not coin that to know
it's a term that researchers use
satisficers that is ficers and so so
maximize that it's not gonna roll off
the tongue so maximizers are people who
will let lessly research every possible
option when it comes to making a
decision it's not a source on the other
hand our people who maybe do a little
bit less research but come to where this
is in a much sooner but to the research
actually shows that satisficers in the
end are more satisfied with the
decisions that they ultimately make okay
what's the difference between you know I
was always raised don't settle when
you're saying just get it done as part
of you actually settling on something
because you always think I could make it
if you think you could make it better
why not try to do that so you're never
gonna end that line of thinking because
you're never gonna achieve something
that you feel is 100% perfect and so it
is really just kind of a little shift in
mindset of knowing that you're never
going to achieve perfection so you have
to be okay with the realization that
it's not perfect but it's done and
hopefully it's good enough yeah that's a
very difficult thing for some people I
mean particularly who are perfectionists
right knowing the moment when to let go
right I mean is that you do reach that
point of diminishing returns where you
can keep making changes keep making
edits but you're really just making it
different you're not making it better so
you say you you wrote about something
called a mostly fine decision yes so the
NFT something that I've written a lot
about before and so that is that really
that point where you think you've
invested probably a little too much time
in something and you just think okay I
may not reach the absolute most 100 cent
perfect conclusion or decision but it's
a mostly fine one and I'm satisfied with
the outcome well I'm mostly fine with
how this segment I was
I was to that city that we gotta go
thank you very much